I want to continue and complete volume two beginning with October the 14th, 1899.
Hope is the peacemaking mother. Now we've had a good bit on this before and it's good to put it
all together. This morning I felt a little disturbed and all annihilated within myself.
I saw myself as if the Lord wanted to drive me away from him, or God what a harrowing pain
this is. And when I was in such a state, blessed Jesus came with a little rope in his hand
and pounding on my heart three times he told me, "Peace, peace, peace, don't you know that the
kingdom of hope is a kingdom of peace." Okay? So we had a message on this previously in September
19th 1899. The kingdom of hope is a kingdom of peace. So I want to give you Jeremiah 29, 11,
and it is that the Lord promised us a future full of hope. So it is a kingdom of peace and that the
right of this hope is justice. You, when you see my justice, arming itself against the people,
enter into the kingdom of hope and investing yourself with the most powerful qualities she
possesses, rise up to my throne and do as much as you can to disarm the armed man. The armed man
is justice. And you will do this with the most eloquent, the most tender and the most compassionate
voices, with the most compelling reasons and the most heated prayers which hope herself will dictate
to you. Now this is the intercession that the victim soul has to make on behalf of souls. And
remember Genesis 18, Abraham, interceding for Sodom and Gomorrah. But when you see that hope
or self is about to support the rights of justice, which are absolutely necessary, I'm wanting to
give them up, would be wanting to give affront to herself, which cannot be, then conform to me
and surrender to justice. Louisa said she was terrified more than ever for having to surrender
to justice and said to him, Lord, how can I do this? It seems impossible to me. The mere
thought that you have to chastise people I cannot tolerate, because they are your images,
Genesis 127 and Romans 829. Yet this is nothing. But what tortures me the most is having to see you,
I would almost say being struck by yourself, slapped, scurged, grieved by yourself,
because the chastisement will pour onto your own members. Your own members, of course, is the
church, the body of Christ, 1 Corinthians 12, 12 to 30. And therefore she said, you yourself will
suffer. Tell me my soul and only good, how will my heart be able to bear seeing you suffer struck
by your own self? If creatures make you suffer, there are always creatures, and it is more tolerable,
but this is so hard I can't swallow it. Therefore, I cannot conform to you, nor can I surrender.
Notice her incredible freedom, even in the presence of the Almighty. And the Lord moved
to pity at all, touched by my words, she said, assumed an afflicted but kind appearance and said,
my daughter, you are right, that I will be struck in my own members, the members of the church.
So much so that in hearing you speak, I feel all my interior move to compassion and mercy,
and I feel my heart split with tenderness. But believe me, chastisements are necessary.
And if you don't want to see me struck a little bit now, you'll see me struck more terribly later.
In other words, people will get worse, they won't get better, because they will offend me more.
Would this not grieve you more? Therefore, conform to me, otherwise you will force me
not to tell you anything anymore so as not to see you grieved. And with this, you would deny me,
Jesus said, the relief I receive in conversing with you. I yes, you would reduce me to silence,
with no one with whom to pour out my pains, and therefore no one to share with.
Who can say how embittered I was left with his words, Louisa said, and Jesus almost wanting
to distract me from my affliction resumed his teaching about hope, telling me, my daughter,
do not be disturbed, hope is peace. And just as I in the very act in which I make justice remain
in the most perfect peace, you too, by immersing yourself in hope, must remain at peace.
The soul who is at peace, by wanting to afflict yourself, becoming disturbed or losing trust,
would run into the misfortune of one who, though possessing millions and millions of coins,
and being queen of various kingdoms keeps fantasizing and lamenting, saying, what shall I live on?
How shall I clothe myself? I am dying of starvation. I am so unhappy. I will be reduced to the
meagerist misery and I will end up dying. In other words, the woman is suffering from imagination,
and Louisa is being warned not to let your imagination run riot. If you are a very imaginative person,
you can cause yourself more trouble in the imagination by just imagining what things are like.
And then, Jesus said, and this fictitious queen, while she says this, she cries and she sighs and
she spends her days in sadness and squalor immersed in the greatest melancholy. But this isn't all.
The worst thing about her is that if she sees her treasures, if she walks within her properties,
instead of rejoicing, she afflicts herself more, thinking of her nearing end. And if she sees food,
she doesn't want to touch it to sustain herself, and if anybody tries to persuade her by letting
her touch her riches with her own hands, showing her that it cannot be said that she will be reduced
to awful misery, she's not convinced she remains dazed and cries even more about her sad lot.
What would people say about her? Surely that she was completely crazy, and it shows that she has no
reason and that she has lost her brains. And the reason for this is clear and it cannot be otherwise.
Yes, it can happen that she may run into the misfortune over which she's actually fantasizing.
In other words, you think about something so much that it becomes reality. But in what way,
by going out of our kingdoms, by abandoning all of our riches, by going into foreign lands in the
midst of barbarian people, where no one will dain to give her a crumb of bread. Here is how the
fantasy will become a reality. But what used to be false is now true. But what has been the cause
of it? Who should be blamed for a change of state that is so sad? It is her perfidious and
obstinate will. That's the bit you underline. The Lord is trying to tell us that we are our
own worst enemies. And if we don't take on this perfidious and obstinate will and lay it down
before the divine will, then we're certainly not going anywhere fast. Such is precisely the soul
who, in possession of hope, are wanting to become disturbed and discouraged is already the greatest
madness. And Louisa said, "Our Lord, how can a soul be always at peace living in hope?
And if the soul commits a sin, how can she be at peace?" And Jesus said, "In the act of sinning,
the soul already goes out of the kingdom of hope because sin and hope cannot be together."
After all, Jesus had said, "I am hope." So God and sin are incompatible. That's your
Hebrews 12, 14. Nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God. Even common sense
believes that each one is obliged to respect, preserve, and cultivate what belongs to them.
Who is that man who goes into his properties and burns all that he possesses? Who does not
keep his possessions jealously? I believe no one. Now, the soul who lives in hope by sinning already
offends hope. And if it were in her power, she would burn up all the goods that hope possesses.
Then she would find herself in the misfortune of that lady who abandoning her goods goes to live
in foreign lands. That means out of the kingdom. In the same way by sin, going out of this peace,
making mother hope so tender and compassionate, who reaches the point of nourishing her with
her own flesh, because after all, hope is Jesus, and he feeds us in the most holy Eucharist.
So she feeds us with her own flesh, which is Jesus in the Eucharist, the primary object of our hope.
The soul goes to live in the midst of barbarian people, which are the demons,
who, denying her the slightest refreshment, nourish her with nothing but poison, which is sin.
Yet, what does this peacemaking mother do? Does she perhaps remain indifferent while the soul
moves away from her? I don't know. She cries, she prays, she calls her with the most tender
and the most moving voices. She goes after her, and when she leads her back into her kingdom,
only then is she content. So that's Luke 15, verse 1, 7, 10, and 21, the story of the prodigal
son going out of the father's house, leaving all the privileges of the father's house behind
and having to return. My sweet Jesus continues telling me, "The nature of hope is peace,
and what she is by nature, the soul who lives in the bosom of this peacemaking mother acquires
by grace." That's Philippians 4, 7, the peace that passes all understanding and guards our hearts
and our minds in Christ Jesus. And in the very act of speaking these words by means of an intellectual
light that's infused knowledge, blessed Jesus makes me see through the simile of a mother what
this hope has done for human beings. Oh what a moving and most tender scene, if all could see it,
even the hardest hearts would cry with contrition and all would grow so fond of her that it would
become impossible for them to detach themselves even for one moment from her maternal knees.
I will now try to save what I understood and what I can. Man used to live in chains,
a slave to the devil, that's John 844, condemned to eternal death without the hope of being able
to live again to eternal life. Everything was lost and his destiny was given over to ruin.
This mother, hope, lived in heaven united with the father and the Holy Spirit because hope is Jesus,
blissful and happy with them, but it seemed that she was not content, she wanted her children,
her dear images, the most beautiful work that came out of her hands, Colossians 1 16 B,
second half of the birth. And she wanted her children to be around her. Now while she was in
heaven her eyes were intent on man who was lost on the earth. She's all occupied with how to save
these beloved children of hers and in seeing that these children can in no way satisfy the divinity
even at the cost of any sacrifice because they are greatly inferior to it. What does this compassionate
mother do? She sees that there's no other way to save the children than to give her own life
to save theirs, taking their pains and miseries upon herself. And by doing everything that they
were supposed to do for themselves. Okay, for all of that I want to give you a Proverbs 8 31,
God delights to be with the children of men, Matthew 18 21 to 35 and Philippians 2 verses 6 to 11.
So what does she think of doing? This loving mother presents herself before the divine
justice with tears in her eyes, with the most tender voices, with the most compelling reasons
of what her magnanimous heart dictates to her. And she says, I ask for grace for my lost children.
I don't have the heart to see them separated from me. I want to save them at any cost, Philippians
2, 5. And even though I see that there's no other way but to lay down my own life,
I want to do it as long as they may acquire theirs. What do you want from them, reparation?
I will repair for them, glory and honor. I will glorify and honor you for them.
Thanksgiving, I will thank you for them. Everything you want from them, I will give to you provided
that I have them with me, reigning, John 1724. The divinity moved in seeing the tears and the
love of this compassionate mother and persuaded by her compelling reasons, it feels inclined to
love these children. The divine persons cry together over their misfortune and conclude in a chord
that they accept the sacrifice of the life of this mother, being fully satisfied in order to
re-acquire the children. As soon as the decree is signed, I want to give you Hebrews 10,
verses 5 to 7, and Philippians 2, 6 to 11. As soon as the decree is signed,
immediately she descends from heaven and comes upon the earth and lays down her royal garments,
which she had in heaven, that's all described in Philippians 2, 6 to 11. She clothes herself with
human miseries as if she were the most miserable slave, and she lives in the most extreme poverty
in the most unheard of sufferings amid the scorns which are most unbearable to the human being.
She does nothing but cry and intercede for her beloved children. But that which is most
stupefying both about this mother and about these children is that while she loves these children
so much, instead of receiving with open arms this mother who is coming to save them, they do the
opposite. So I want to give you Luke 2, 7, Matthew chapter 2 in the persecution of the infant Jesus.
Matthew 20 verses 1 to 16, John 7, 20 and 26. No one wants to receive her or recognize her.
On the contrary, they let her go wandering, they despise her, they begin to plot how to kill this
mother so tender who loves them so passionately. What will such a tender mother do in seeing
herself required it so badly by her ungrateful children? Will she stop? No. On the contrary,
she becomes more ignited with love for them and she runs from one point to another to gather them
and place them on her lap. Oh how she toils, how she struggles to the point of dripping sweat,
not only of water but also of blood. Luke 22 verses 41 to 44. She gives herself not a moment
of respite. She's always in the act to operate their salvation and she provides for all their needs.
She remedies all their ills past, present and future. In some, there is nothing that she will
not do in order to dispose for them for good. But what did the children do? Have they perhaps
repented of their ingratitude in receiving her? Have they changed their thoughts in favor of this
mother? No, no. They scowl at her. They dishonor her with the vilest calomies. They procure her
aprobrium, scorns and confusion. They beat her with every kind of scourge, reducing her to a
complete wound. Romans 5.5, Isaiah 52.5. And they finish by making her die the most infamous death
that can be found in the midst of cruel spasms and pains. But what did this mother do in the
midst of so many pains? Will she perhaps hate these children so unruly and arrogant? No, she won't.
Never. It's then that she loves them even more passionately than ever, offering her pains for
their salvation and breathing her last word with the word of peace and forgiveness.
Oh, my beautiful mother. Oh, dear hope, how admirable you are. I love you. Oh, please,
keep me always on your lap, and I will be the happiest in the world. While I am determined to
stop speaking about hope, a voice resounds everywhere within me. Hope contains all good, past, present,
and future. And the one who lives on her lap and is raised on her knees, whatever she wants,
she will obtain. What does the soul want? Is it glory and honor? Hope will give her the greatest
honor and glory on earth among all people, and in heaven she will glorify her eternally.
Maybe she wants riches. Oh, mother hope is extremely rich, and what is more by giving her goods to
her children, her riches are not in the least diminished. Moreover, these riches are not fleeting
and passing. They are eternal. Does she want pleasures and contentments? Ah, yes. This hope
contains within herself all possible pleasures and tastes, which can be found in heaven and on earth,
so much so that no one will ever be able to equal her. And one who nourishes herself from her
breast enjoys them to her fill, and oh, how happy and content is she. Does she want to be learned
and wise? This mother hope contains the most sublime knowledge within herself. Even more,
she is the master of all masters. And one who lets herself be taught by her learns the science
of true sanctity. In some hope provides us with everything in such a way that one is if one is
weak, she gives him strength. If another is stained, hope instituted the sacraments and in them prepared
to a bath for his sins. If one is hungry or thirsty, this compassionate mother gives us the most
beautiful, the most delicious food, which is her most delicate flesh and as a drink for most precious
blood. What else can this peacemaking mother hope do? And who else is similar to her? Ah, she alone
has reconciled heaven and earth. Hope has united faith and charity with herself and has formed that
indissolable link between the human and divine nature. But who is this mother? Who is this hope?
She is Jesus the Christ, who operated our redemption and formed the hope of man astray. Most wonderful
ode that is. October the 16th, 1899, Jesus speaks about chastisements again. This morning my sweet
Jesus was not coming. I'd not seen him since last night when he showed himself with an appearance
that moved one to pity and struck fear at the same time. He wanted to hide so as not to see the
chastisements which he himself was sending over the people and the way in which he was going to
destroy them. Oh God what a harrowing sight never before seen. While waiting and waiting in my interior
I kept saying how is it that he's not coming? Who knows whether he does not come because I do not
conform to his justice. But how can I do this? It seems almost impossible for me to say fear
full on task to her. Then again I kept saying he's not coming because the confessor is not sending
him to me. While I was thinking of this I just barely saw him almost a shadow and he told me
do not fear the authority of priests is limited. According to the measure in which they are willing
to pray me to come to you and to offer you as a victim to make you suffer so that I may spare the
people so will I heal them and spare them in the act in which I send the chastisements.
If then they don't give it a thought neither will I have any regard for them. This is a very
important point here because Louisa has been told she must be obedient at all costs. She must
be the priest as she would obey the Lord. And here at the same time Jesus is saying that there is a
job for the priest to do and the more they are involved in using her as a victim for others
the more the Lord will be compassionate and heal them. Now you've heard Louisa pray over and over
again that something in the priest needed to be healed and he says this is the condition on which
I will heal him. So October the 21st 1899 earthly good must serve for the sanctification of man not
as idols. After going through most bitter days of privation I was feeling tired and exhausted
though I kept offering those very pains saying Lord you know how much being deprived of you
costs me but I resigned myself to your most holy will offering this most bitter pain as a means
to prove my love and to placate you. Now that is the response that Jesus wants from her not to have
her complaining that he's not coming. These bothers these annoyances this weariness the coldness that
I feel I intend to send you as messengers of praise and of reparation for myself and for all
creatures past present and future. This I have and this I offer you in other words we only offer
him what we have and if you only have his privation well that's all you have to offer. Surely you accept
the sacrifice of the good will when one offers you what he can with no reserve what come she says I
can take no more. Oftentimes I had the temptation to conform to justice thinking that I myself was
the cause of his not coming. In fact in these past days Jesus had told me that if I did not conform
I would force him not to come and not to tell me anything anymore so as not to grieve me but I did
not have the heart to do it more so since not even obedience consented to it so the priest doesn't
agree either. While I was amid this bitterness first a light came and then a voice saying
according to the measure in which man meddles in earthly things so does he move away and lose
esteem for eternal goods. That's true of all of us but more true if you're dealing with priests
and those consecrated God. I gave riches that they might use them for their sanctification
but they've used them to offend me and to form an idol in their hearts and I will destroy them
and their riches with them so I want to give you the letter of James chapter 5 verses 1 to 6
and I want to give you Sam 49 and this is the fate of all the rich. After this I saw my dearest
Jesus and so in suffering offended and indignant with the people as to strike terror. Immediately
I began to say to him Lord I offer you your own wounds I offer you your blood the most holy use
of your senses which you made during the course of your mortal life to repair for the offenses
and for the bad use of the senses which creatures do with you. Now we make this prayer in the divine
will and union with all of their actions and merits and sufferings of Jesus and Jesus assuming
a serious look almost thundering said do you know how the senses of creatures have become like the
screams of fierce animals which drive men away with their roars not allowing them to draw near.
The rot and the multiplicity of sins is such that it spurts from their senses which force me to
flee. I want to give you Romans chapter 1 Hebrews 12 14 Ezekiel chapter 10 and 11. I've given you
some of those references before you see without holiness no one will ever see God and the filthiness
of the flesh keeps God very far away. Louisa said "A Lord how indignant I see you if you want to
continue sending chastisements I want to come otherwise I want to go out at this stage to Corinthians 5
8 to 9. Why remain in it since I can no longer offer myself as victim to spare the people and
he addressing me with seriousness so much so that I felt terrified he said you want to touch the two
extremes either you want me to do nothing or you want to die I mean give us a break there must be
something in between are you not content with the fact that people are spared in part when you go to
Genesis 18 verses 22 to 32 Abraham was prepared to go see it with the Lord and go down from 50 to
45 and down to 5 and so on. Do you think that Corrato is the best or the least in offending me
is the fact that I spirited compared to other towns something trivial so content yourself
and cam yourself and while I occupy myself with chastising the people you accompany me with your
size and with your sufferings praying that the very chastisements may turn out to the conversion
of the people in other words instead of opposing me he said why don't you work with me and we will
produce this together so October the 22nd 1899 we're dealing with the cross again Jesus continues to
make himself seen afflicted the moment he came he threw himself into my arms totally exhausted
almost wanting refreshment he shared with me a little bit of his sufferings and then he told me
my daughter the way of the cross is a way strewn with stars and as one walks through it those stars
change into the most luminous suns now the sun is a source of light and life okay and that's the way
in which it is actually used here the stars change into the most luminous suns what will be the
happiness of the soul who for all eternity is being surrounded by these suns furthermore the great
reward that I give to the cross is that there's no measure either of wit or of length it is almost
incomprehensible to the human mind and this because in bearing crosses there can be nothing human
it's all divine and so the divine way of saving souls is through the cross the way to reach divinity
fast is through the cross okay so October the 24th 1899 the cause of chastisements
this morning my adorable Jesus came and transported me outside of myself into the midst of the people
Jesus seemed to look at them with eyes of compassion and the very chastisements appeared as infinite
mercies of his come out of his most loving heart so I want to give you Sam one four five verse 17
God only ever acts out of love that's his only motivation when he sends us chastisement it's because
he wants to clean us up he wants to turn us around turn us towards heaven so that we can have heaven
eternally then turning to me he told me my daughter man is the product of a divine being and since our
food is love always reciprocal alike and constant among the three divine persons since man came out
of our hands and he came from pure and disinterested love he's like a particle of our food now this
particle has become bitter for us not only this but the majority of them by moving away from us
have made themselves pasture for the infernal flames and food for the implacable hatred of demons
our capital enemies and theirs this is the main cause of our sorrow in the loss of souls they are
ours they are something that belongs to us likewise the cause that pushes me to chastise them is the
great love I have for them okay Jeremiah 31 3 I have loved you with the never lasting love and so
I want to place their souls in safety Jesus said and when you know the purpose of the chastisement
it's so much easier and Louisa said our Lord it seems that this time you've no other words to say
than about chastisements your power has other means to save these souls and then if I were certain
that all the pain would fall upon them and you would remain free without suffering with them I
would resign myself acte nine four but I see that you are already suffering very much from those
chastisements what will happen if you continue sending them and Jesus said even though I suffer
love pushes me to send heavier scourges and this because in order to make man enter into himself
and recognize what his being is there is no means more powerful to make him see himself undone okay
so there's nothing only pain and suffering and tragedy that's the way the Lord sees it now since
God is our maker he actually knows how we work and we know ourselves too that a tragedy may not
actually change a person it may change some and it may not change others the same tragedy that
will bring about repentance in one could bring about hardness of heart in another so Jesus continues
it seems that the other means make him grow bolder so if he uses mercy all the time and no
chastisements man gets only bolder and says ah sure God won't do anything you know God doesn't
even see us he doesn't notice us therefore conform to my justice I see well that the love you have
for me pushes you very much not to conform to me but you don't have the heart to see me suffer
but my mother too loved me more than all creatures no one can equal her yet in order to save these
souls she conform to justice and she resigned herself to see me suffer very much if my mother did this
could you not do it yourself and as Jesus was speaking I felt my will being drawn so much to his
that I almost was almost unable anymore to withstand not conforming to his justice
I did not know what to say so much was I convinced however I've not yet manifested my will this is
Louisa's extraordinary personal freedom other people would just simply jump without thinking
what Louisa knows she must give it to the confessor and get the agreement of the church
Jesus disappeared and I remained in this doubt whether I should conform or not October the 25th
1899 this is the echo of the love of God and the echo of the ingratitude of creatures
my most sweet Jesus continues to manifest himself almost always in the same way
this morning he added my daughter my love towards creatures is so great that it resounds like an
echo in the celestial regions it fills the atmosphere and diffuses over the whole earth
but what is the response that human beings give to this loving echo
add they requite me with an echo of ingratitude poisonous filled with every kind of bitterness
and sins with an echo that's almost deadly fit only for wounding me but I will depopulate the face
of the earth so that this echo resounding with poison may not deafen my ears now this is a long
distance prophecy put in your amos three seven there because it has been partially fulfilled in
world war one and world war two but there is a world war three on the way and the depopulation
of the earth is spoken about in Revelation 16 when two-thirds of humanity would be wiped out that's
called depopulation Louisa said our Lord what are you saying and Jesus said I act just like
a pitying doctor who has the extreme remedies for his children and these children are full of wounds
what does this father and doctor do who loves the children more than his very life
will he let these wounds become gangrenous will he let them die for fear that by applying the
knife and the fire they may not suffer no not if he loves them even though he will feel as if those
instruments were applied to himself in spite of this he grabs the knife he rips and cuts the flesh
and he applies it to the poison and the fire to prevent corruption from advancing any further
that's the whole point the chastisements try to stop this poison from getting any worse even though
many times it happens that in these operations the poor children die this was not the will of the
father doctor that his will was to see them healed that's what i'm like i wound in order to heal them
i destroy them in order to resurrect them if any parish this is not my will it is only the effect
of their wickedness and obstinate will john five versus nineteen to twenty five it is the
effect of this poisonous echo which they want to keep sending me to the point of seeing themselves
destroyed louisa said tell me my only good how could i sweeten this poisonous echo for you which
afflicts you so much and he said the only means is that you always do all of your actions with
the sole purpose of pleasing me now this is a vip message okay and this is one of the steps
along the journey into divine will that all our actions are done only and absolutely to please
jesus we do it for love of him that's the highest thing so i want to give you john eight twenty nine
john fourteen thirty one and jr. enemy six four to ten so i would read that again the only means is
that you always do all of your actions with the sole purpose of pleasing me and that you employ
all of your senses and your powers for the purpose of loving me and of glorifying me let your every
thought that's two carinthians ten five every thought must be captured and given to christ so
you can see that the battle to let the lord reign is completely an interior battle with us
let your every thought word and everything else that means all your actions movements and steps
want nothing but the love you have for me in this way your echo will rise pleasant to my throne
and will sweeten my hearing okay so this is the total and absolute gift of self
so october the twenty eighth eighteen ninety nine who am i and who are you we've had this before
this morning my beloved jesus came surrounded by light and looking at me as though penetrating
me everywhere so much so that i felt annihilated and he told me who am i and who are you now we've
had this before and the light is one john one five and our nothingness and yet we are utterly
privileged is sam eight these words penetrated me deep into the marrow of my bones and i could see
the infinite distance that exists between the infinite and the finite between the all and the
nothing not only this but i could also see the malice of this nothing and how it had covered itself
with mud it seemed to me like a fish that swims in the water so was my soul swimming in rot
amid worms and other things which are only fit for striking horror at the site so i want to give
you asiah chapter six verses one to six for that oh god what an abominable site my soul would have
wanted to flee before the sight of god thrice holy but with two more words he binds me and these are
what is my love for you jeremaia thirty one three and what is your return for me so first you see
the infinite all holy absolute god total purity total holiness and by comparison were filthy rot
so at that point you want to flee like the souls into pargotry or hell and then he says now i want
to show you my love and i'm looking for your love in return now while at the first words i would have
wanted to flee frightened from his presence at the second words what is my love for you i found
myself sunken bound by the love from all sides in such a way that my existence was a product of his
love divine will and love is the summary of the 36 volumes and that's just the way it is so
the person whom we call love is divine will the person whom we call divine will and love
is faith is hope is love is obedience so if this love would cease luisa realized i would no longer
exist it seemed to me that the beats of my heart the intelligence the operating of my intelligence
and even my breath were a product of this love i was swimming in him and even if i wanted to flee
it seemed impossible for me to do it because his love surrounded me everywhere my love then
seemed like a little drop of water thrown into the sea that's how it is and this drop just disappears
and can no longer be distinguished how many things i understood if i want to tell them it would be too
long then jesus disappeared and i was left all confused i saw myself all sin and in my interior
i kept imploring forgiveness and mercy after a little while my only good came back i felt all
soaked with bitterness and sorrow for my sins and he told me my daughter when a soul is convinced
that she has done evil in offending me she already performs the office of the magdalene
who bathed at my feet with her tears anointed them with bam and dried them with her hair
that's Luke 7 36 to 50 when the soul begins to look within herself at the evil she has done
and she feels sorrow for it she prepares a bath for my wounds in seeing her evil she receives
bitterness and feels sorrow for it and by this she comes to anoint my wounds with such an exquisite
bam from this self-knowledge and we've pointed out before several times that this self-knowledge is
absolutely vital from this self-knowledge the soul would want to make reparation and in seeing her
past in gratitude she feels love towards god who is so good arise in her and she would want to lay
down her life to prove her love and this is the hair like so many gold chains that binds her to my
love like Magdalene's hair was used to wipe the feet of Jesus so the Lord has shown us there how
the memory of our sins should lead us into not only repentance but into loving god with all our being
so October the 29th this is a very very very important message October the 29th 1899 it's how
to form an interior dwelling for Jesus my adorable Jesus continues to come but this morning as soon
as he came he took me in his arms and carried me outside of myself now she's not usually going into
and out of the body experience in the arms of the Lord being in those arms I understood many
things and especially that in order to be in the arms of our Lord freely and even to enter his heart
with all ease and to go out of it as the soul best pleases and not to be a weight or a bother
and blessed Jesus it is absolutely necessary to strip oneself of everything so I want to give you
John 10 38 B so if we're to go in and out of the the Lord's arms freely then we can only do it by
stripping ourselves of everything of the world the flesh and the devil we've got to strip ourselves
of our own ego we've got to go to him naked and nothing then he's completely free therefore with
all my heart I said to him my dear and only good what I ask of you for me is that you strip me of
everything because I see well that in order to be clothed again by you and to live in you and for
you to live again in me it is necessary for me to have not even a shadow of that which doesn't
belong to you so I want to give you Galatians 220 I no longer live Christ lives in me and one
Corinthians 3 16 no you not that you are the temple of the living God and Jesus all kindness
told me my daughter the main thing so that I may enter into a soul and form my dwelling is total
detachment from everything now we've come across this before and we're going to come across it
again because he keeps repeating things from different angles so that somehow we may get the
message total detachment from everything without this not only can I not dwell in her but not even
any of the virtues can form their residence in her now to form its residence is stable living in her
after this once the soul has made everything go out of herself then do I enter Sam 127
verses 1 and 2 if the Lord doesn't build a house the labors labor in vain so after this once the
soul has made everything go out of herself then do I enter and united with the will of the soul
we build a house that's your Sam 127 the foundations of it what this are humility and our nothingness
and the deeper they are the higher and stronger the walls will be just ask any of the people who
build skyscrapers and they'll tell you the higher up you want to go the deeper the foundations have
got to go in so the lessons that we're learning here in volumes one and two cannot in any sense
be put aside they're utterly extremely important the foundations are based on humility and the
deeper they are the higher and stronger the walls will be these walls will be built with stones of
mortification now he has come across that message several times and we will have plenty more in the
first four volumes and they're cemented together with the gold of charity that's divine love it's
not human feeling after the walls have been built I like a most excelling painter plaster it and
form it with the most excelling paintings Ephesians 210 where God's work of art not with lime and
water but with the merits of my passion represented by the lime and with the colors of my blood
represented by the water this serves to protect it well from rains and snows and from any shock
then come the doors and in order for them to be solid like wood and not subject to woodworm
silence is necessary which forms the death of the exterior senses now this is an interior silence
that cams absolutely everything in order to keep the house a guardian is necessary to watch over
it everywhere inside and out and this guardian is the holy fear of god which guards it against
any inconvenience wind or anything else that may threaten it this fear will be the safeguard of
the house i want to give you sam two eleven sam five seven sam twenty two twenty three sam thirty
four verses nine and eleven so this holy fear will be the safeguard of this house which will cause
one to operate not out of fear of penalty but out of fear of offending the master of the house
so the thing we fear is actually sin this holy fear must do nothing but do everything to please
god sam one one one verse ten sam one one five verse eleven proverbs eight thirteen and loads more
in the bible we must do everything to please god with no other intention we've been told
that from the very beginning and the lord will keep repeating it because it's so important the
only motivation he wants from us is love that we will do everything to please him then this house
must be adorned and filled with treasures these treasures must be not others than holy desires
and tears these were the treasures of the old testament and in them they found their salvation
in the fulfillment of their vows their consolation in sufferings they found their strength in some
they placed all their fortune in their desire for the future redeemer Matthew 13 17 Luke 10 24
and in this desire they operated as athletes a soul without desire operates almost as dead
everything is boredom bother and rancor even virtues themselves there's nothing that she likes
and she walks almost crawling on the path of good but all the opposite for the soul who desires
who really wants to go to heaven who really wants to be a saint and so on nothing is a
wait for her everything is joy she flies she finds her tastes and even in the pains that are giving
to her that's Hebrews 12-2 this because there is an anticipated desire and the things which are
first desired are then loved and as one loves them one finds the most pleasant delights in them
therefore this desire must be entertained even before the house is built that means if you don't
want to become a saint and if you don't want to become one with god in his divine will it's not
going to happen because you won't do anything the ornaments of this house will be the most precious
stones the most expensive pearls and the gems of this life of mine always founded upon suffering
but pure suffering now pure suffering is suffering that is done only for the love of god and since the
one who dwells in it is the giver of every good he places in it the endowment of all virtues he
perfumes it with the most gentle odors he makes lovely flowers give off their fragrance he makes
a celestial melody among the most pleasant resound he makes one breathe even the air of paradise
i forgot to say that one must see whether there is domestic peace and this must be nothing but the
recollection and silence of the interior senses it's very difficult to become a saint if you're
surrounded by noise and disturbance outside and most particularly inside so the recollection and
silence of the interior senses after this louisa said i continue to be in the arms of our lord and
i was all stripped that stripping of course is spiritual not physical in the meantime i saw the
confessor there present and jesus told me but it seems to me that he wanted to play with me and
see what i would say in other words he was testing her my daughter you've stripped yourself of everything
and you know that when one is stripped someone else is needed who takes care of clothing him
nourishing him and who gives him a place where he can stay where do you want to stay in the arms of
the confessor or in mind oh that's a test isn't it and as he was saying this he did the act of placing
me in the arms of the confessor i began to insist that i didn't want to go and that he insisted that
he wanted it and after a little bit of argument he told me don't fear i'll keep you in my arms
and so he's testing her to see just how great the obedience is so this is the last text now in volume
two october the thirteenth 1899 the threats of chastisement for Rome this morning my good jesus
came all afflicted and the first words he spoke to me were poor Rome how you will be destroyed now
this prophecy has not yet been fulfilled okay in looking at you i cry over you and he was saying
this with such tendernesses to arouse compassion but i couldn't understand whether it was only about
the people or also the buildings since i had the obedience not to conform to justice but to pray
i said to him my beloved jesus when it's about chastisements we must no longer argue only pray
and so i began to pray to kiss his wounds and to make acts of reparation and while i was doing
this every now and then he would say to me my daughter do not use violence on me that's Matthew
11 12 the kingdom of god suffers violence and the violent shaked by force by doing this you want to
use violence on me by force so cam yourself he said and louisa said lord it's obedience that
wants it so sorry about that so he added the river of iniquities is so great as to reach the point
of preventing the redemption of souls and prayer alone and these wounds of mine can prevent this
raging river from absorbing them all into itself whoops he's saying now Rome of course is the Vatican
it's not just the city of Rome and in 1975 there was a great prophecy given in the Vatican i was
present when it was given and we were told yes not one stone was going to be left on another
that it was going to be destroyed just as not one stone was left on another of the temple in
Jerusalem either and the reason was the same and that is the iniquity that actually has come there
and so let's just finish this again poor Rome how you will be destroyed and then he added the river
of iniquities is so great as to reach the point of preventing the redemption of soul he's not going
to allow that and prayer alone and these wounds of mine can prevent this raging river from absorbing
them all into itself well in revelation chapter 12 we're told that satan would send a raging river
to destroy the woman which is the chart and that raging river is there today and it's a river of
filth but we have the wounds of Jesus we have the divine will we have prayer we have sacrifice
we can make reparation we can save souls that's the end of volume two